[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas voulu me coucher ce soir
pour danser avec vous beaucoup d'entre
eux de potes plus mais chaque personne
ici présent est une lumière une source
de chaleur qui rendra notre ciel plus
bleu prends ton bon laisse l'espace d'un
instant vous les étoiles moi le soleil
brillons ensemble sur un Entremont elles
m'ont donné
[Musique]
encore un avion dans le ciel qui se
prend pour une étoile comme rigoler
toute la Casio
prototype
comme moi tu vas finir par te casser le
vieux je serai la montagne tu prends les
ailes
je serai l'étoile tu prends la tête on a
beau trop tourner tant que des mauvaises
on sent l'éléphant tu seras là
on sera le bon temps tu seras le souci
tu donneras ton avis sur chacun de mes
choix tu t'es rend des autres ce que
l'on pense
[Musique]
on fera le soleil tu sors un homme le
masque tant que tu mets en lumière tout
à côté
[Musique]
on fera le soleil tu sors mal dans les
masques tant tu mets en lumière tout est
sous on te serre la main et on se rend
compte
[Musique]
encore un avion dans le ciel qui se
prend pour une étoile qui aimerait
[Musique]
volée
on sera l'éléphant tu seras là
on sera le bon temps tu seras les soucis
tu donneras ton avis sur chacun de nos
choix
tu penses de toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle s'appelle
la même petite fesse on perd le nord
dans la peau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on perd le nord dans leur cœur
enlève la pierre que tu caches chutes
des fois je fais de la merde mais c'est
jamais ma faute car le problème
je roulais comme chacun les conseils je
connais à part décrochettes allez
prochain on avance tous nos projets mais
j'ai promis à Mathieu de la faire
voyager alors j'enchaîne sur scène et
fume l'herbe comme à couper sur pied
[Musique]
le poids tombe
je regarde le ciel je sais même plus
s'il fait beau pour sauver le moment
chacun
[Musique]
aurait comme ce que l'on s'aime c'était
un danseur
de la merde
et toi envers même c'est la même on
récolte
[Musique]
tempo
et le plastique reste je traverse ces
saisons avec la même petite peste on
perd le nord dans nos cœurs salut c'est
cool
le monde est beau et celui-là c'est le
nom
[Musique]
mais ça fait combien de fois j'étais
chez dans le temps beaucoup
combien l'humain enfermé dans les camps
beaucoup
combien le succès de pousser de cession
de pression beaucoup combien le
scorporer
d'enfants sont tombés à la mer et
personne n'est venu de ce dépôts
combien dure enfermé dans les grands
coucous
combien d'enfants sont tombés combien de
fois tu t'es dites dans les barrières
combien de temps
je me souviens
la vie est dur comme un lit japonais
beaucoup combien d'habits que j'ai bon
un peu plus de 100000 abonnés combien de
mermodies dans la rue Becky son côté
combien de pays dans lequel l'industrie
du XIX de léger pas diplôme le
pote mais ça fait combien de fois j'ai
péché dans le temps beaucoup
combien les mains enfermés dans les
grands beaucoup
combien le succès de pousser de cession
de pression beaucoup combien de secondes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on perd d'un homme dans la pièce salut
c'est cool tu as bien beau chant
tristesse seulement des progrès celui-là
c'est le loto on lève la pierre que tu
caches tes côtés des fois je fais de la
merde on sait jamais de ma faute
le problème sera toujours les choses
quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une amie
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci encore à toutes les personnes qui
sont déplacées ce soir
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on soutenu la culture leurs
artistes s'amusent
[Musique]
je suis passé dans la gente je regarde
vers le ciel la tête plein de penser
pour les représentent les veines si tu
prends pas le gâteau personne te laisse
je pense très bien le monde avant
d'acheter
[Musique]
comme la synchro laisse-les partir c'est
pas ma grand sapin passer c'est ton âme
viens je te tendrais plus les cinq
doigts je te vois plus du même je
t'écoute plus de la même oreille je te
migrateur
avec le produit de la ferme pas chez moi
il y a que nos weekends
[Musique]
ne passera pas l'hiver
le printemps de manche comme une barre
qu'on ne me demande
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
maintenant
beaucoup de sang dans ma vie mais aucun
ne sont comme vous
[Musique]
beaucoup de sang dans la vie
beaucoup de sang dans ma vie mais aucun
ne sont comme vous
[Musique]
adomae
jamais jamais jamais jamais
jamais est-ce que tu es pas bouger tes
fesses ce soir le Printemps de Bourges
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le taux de vente explose petit bosses
par petit Bose toute la France voit au
monde petit boss petit pause petit pause
partout
[Musique]
je me douche alors me prendre à la dame
à la planche je fais super comme un
[Musique]
le taux de vente explose petit bosse
barbec François au monde petit pause
petit pause petit bosses parties
[Musique]
je suis parti
dans la
[Musique]
dans l'espace je suis dans le viseur de
ma classe
donc jamais je me déplace de l'huile
moteur faut de la graisse alors dans le
bus faut que j'agresse j'en profite donc
jamais ça ton corps si je suis à pied
dans le canapé
[Musique]
dans tes fesses un seul manège dans
l'ivresse je mijote dans la graisse je
fricote dans une pièce et je mets mon
skate dans un sexe début c'est déjà la
maladresse finale tu t'habitues c'est là
ce fort de l'espèce petit bonsoir petit
pouce pour doucement tu augmentes les
doses par petit pause le taux de vente
explose petit boss par petit Flon toute
la France va au mot petit pause petit
pause petit pause par petit pouce petit
boss par petit pouce bon doucement
t'augmente les doses
petit boss par petit Bose
petit pause petit pause petit pause par
[Musique]
petit
merci encore à toutes les personnes qui
sont venues
ce couple je cours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je connais ça tu chantes avec moi ça
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car on est là pour vous faire danser ce
soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la lumière vient à porte dans sa
peinture
[Musique]
où étais-tu caché plus sous le toit
maintenant tu m'as roulé
vas-y sur moi
[Musique]
combien de nuages me reste-t-il à
effacer je regarde vers le ciel par la
boucle de me lasse je vais défoncer la
vie un peu plein qui est tonton
[Musique]
mener voyager parcourir la vie dans un
balai dans de ma jette deux trois petits
rayons on tape sur le côté de mon toit
j'ai maintenant tu es plus fâché soleil
fried sur moi où étais-tu cacher
maintenant plus ou toi maintenant tu
m'as roulais vas-y tire sur moi
prends-moi le soleil que tu as caché
dans tes poches des fois c'est moi là
sur la toile la plus proche demande au
ciel c'est l'avenir sera moche je
recolle le mien avec des petits bouts de
scotch je m'appelle ainsi c'est tant
mieux c'est tant pis malgré tes cancers
tu comptes les contrat moi je pour les
Grands Prix tu crois sur les autres qui
n'ont pas encore compris j'aimerais
pouvoir te dire que je n'ai pas les mots
j'aimerais repentir mais je suis coincé
dans l'écho on n'arrive pas à lire ce
qu'on devrait parapher ici les requins
pas nous apprendre à nager crois-moi le
soleil
toi la plus proche demande au ciel c'est
la vie on sera moche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au cœur de moi
j'ai plus le temps
ici les saisons changent
prends garde-moi
mais
on partira
ici le sol est dense
mais dis-moi qu'est-ce qu'on t'a fait tu
écris ton histoire dans un autre d'un
fait j'aime plus le temps jE Toilette un
fesses et l'avenir noir dans le mainte
café dans la lune dans ma bulle dans ma
tête il parle tout fort mais j'entends
zéro des baies roule ma pauvre car au CP
le soleil m'attend quelque part derrière
les volets on vivra caché comme les
mauvais côtés on traînera de orels les
soirs d'été passez les frontières au
volant d'une jetée j'essaye encore de
savoir qui tu étais regarde toi dans le
ciel bleu chez pétales la lune pour
savoir ce qu'elle veut on oubliera tout
tout ton passé
[Musique]
regarde-moi dans les lunettes au
garde-moi comme la dernière allumette
j'ai plus le temps de faire la même
chose si si les saisons changent un
contre tempo regarde-moi qu'est-ce qu'on
est bien ferme les yeux jusqu'à demain
matin on partira sûrement demain très
tôt ici le soleil danse à contre tempo
mais dis-moi qu'est-ce qu'on t'a fait tu
écris ton histoire dans un autoda faim
j'ai plus le temps je dois les taper si
l'avenir est noir dans le marc de café
dans la lune
dans ma beauté il parle tout fort mais
j'entends zéro des peines je roule ma
pote à ton carreau CP le soleil m'attend
quelque part derrière les volets on
vivra caché comme les mauvais côtés on
traînera dehors les soirées
passez les frontières au volant tu ne
jetais j'essaye encore de savoir qui tu
étais
regarde-toi dans le ciel bleu chez
pétales la lune pour savoir ce qu'elle
veut on oubliera tout ton passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me bats pour toi pour que temps 10 on
se retrouve à l'abri je vois une lumière
s'il vous plaît tout le monde une
lumière un téléphone un briquet
n'importe quoi s'il vous plaît la
lumière
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde tout le monde tout le
monde tout le monde tout le monde tout
le monde tout le monde allez allez allez
allez allez s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
petite Marie
ta petite tes petites mains
tu as versé sur ma vie de milieu danse
petite purée je me bats pour toi pour
que
on se retrouve à l'abri
sous un ciel aussi j'en ai que le milieu
de range je viens du ciel et les étoiles
en train de faire
[Musique]
jouer seulement sur un morceau de
leur amour
[Musique]
sous une tuile de Tonton le ventre la
lune
me renvoie la balle jamais
[Musique]
si tu n'es pas qu'à chaque fois au
soleil de Floride
[Musique]
par musicien tu peux jouer seulement sur
un morceau de
[Musique]
ciel autour
dans la pénombre de ta rue petite mamie
m'entends-tu je rate plus que toi pour
partir
[Musique]
dans la pénombre de ta rue petite Marie
matin
[Musique]
plus que toi
[Applaudissements]
je vous souhaite un excellent festival
tu t'es perdues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tout le monde
applique
[Musique]
il faut masserve tout de ça
combien de minutes 100 minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les lunettes au garde-moi comme la
dernière allumette j'ai plus le temps de
faire la même chose ici le 16 on change
par contre
regarde-moi qu'est-ce qu'on aime bien
faire mon essieux jusqu'à demain matin
on partira sûrement demain traitant ici
le soleil dans 50 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as versé sur ma vie
petite fille je peux pas pour toi pour
que dans
on se retrouve
sous un ciel aussi Charlie je veux
t'entendre maintenant je veux pas toi je
viens du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
de toi dormir
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]